one of the biggest problems we face when
traveling in space is the atrophy our
bodies endure oil in microgravity the
astronauts on the International Space
Station have to exercise several times a
day to maintain their bone and muscle
strength but is there an alternative can
we create artificial gravity I'm sure
you've seen the idea before in movies
like 2001 a Space Odyssey where the
entire space station spins to create
artificial gravity the people inside can
now walk comfortably just like they do
on earth it does this by exploiting
centrifugal force now it seems that
whenever someone mentions centrifugal
force angry mobs will show up in the
comments section declaring it isn't real
which just isn't the case let's see why
NASA developed this huge centrifuge to
test the possibility of simulated
gravity back in the 1960s here we are
looking from an inertial frame of
reference that just means we're looking
from an outside perspective and we can
clearly see that there is no force
pulling the sky outwards it is just as
inertia carrying him forward and the
floor he is walking on provides the
centripetal force to prevent him from
flying off what happens if our reference
frame moves with the astronaut this is
called a rotating reference frame or a
non inertial reference frame to him the
rest of the world is moving and he is
standing stationary in this reference
frame centrifugal force is absolutely a
real and measurable force pushing him
downwards just like gravity the only
thing that is fictitious is his
perception of what is causing it this
occurs because in physics and
engineering we must balance forces the
system has to be in equilibrium Newton's
third law states for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
so centripetal force exists in this
reference frame there has to be a force
pushing em outwards that is centrifugal
force and the moment the rotation stops
it vanishes again so if this works so
well why haven't we seen a spinning
Space Station yet well one problem is
size to make this practical we need a
massive ship which would be incredibly
expensive to get into orbit the
acceleration your body will experience
is directly proportional to the speed
and radius of the space station we can
calculate the gravity Space Station V
from 2001 a Space Odyssey would generate
with some pretty simple math the Space
Station V had a diameter of 300 meters
and sponsz access once ever
60-seconds that would put its gravity at
about the same as the moon's for java
gravity similar to Earth's it would need
to spin once every 24 seconds if we were
to make this a realistic size let's say
the same as the International Space
Station it would need to spin once every
10 seconds this would probably be pretty
disorientating just ask Sandra Bullock
another problem we face on smaller
stations like this is the gradient and
acceleration you would experience
because the acceleration is directly
proportional to the distance to the
rotational Center your head will
experience less artificial gravity than
your feet this would force the blood to
your feet just like when you spin a
bucket of water around this effect
diminishes with larger stations so to
make a practical space station with
artificial gravity the station would
have to be huge which is simply too
expensive
besides the ISS is most valuable to us
as a laboratory to test the effects of
microgravity what if money was not an
issue what would it take to get a space
station like Elysium built for the
mega-rich as an escape from the turmoil
on earth into orbit
Elysium dwarfs space station v measuring
in at 60 kilometers wide and it is
estimated to weigh about a million
metric tons spacex can currently launch
a kilogram into space for about 2700
dollars with their Falcon 9 rocket this
will be reduced to one thousand six
hundred and fifty dollars per kilo when
they launched their Falcon 9 heavy
variant at the end of the year but it
would take over 18,000 launches to bring
the 1 million metric tons to low Earth
orbit that's one point six five trillion
dollars to just get the materials of
Elysium into space with current
technologies then we have to worry about
the cost of materials and engineering
that would go into building something
with this magnitude that is far more
difficult to calculate but we can take
some clues from the ISS it is estimated
to have cost about 150 billion in total
it took 36 shuttle flights that'll cost
a 1.4 billion each to bring the
materials into space that's a total cost
of fifty point four billion dollars so
the launch costs were just 33 percent of
the total cost a conservative estimate
for the cost of Elysium could put it up
five trillion dollars that's sixty two
point three buildings but there are half
a million people onboard Elysium so if
the costs were split between everyone
that would be about 10 million each that
isn't so far-fetched and the price of
space travel is destined to reduce in
future we do have material strong enough
to build a
like this the forces on Elysium would be
similar to the ISS other than the
additional stress created by centripetal
and centrifugal force it's interesting
to note that the designers of Elysium
took note of this the stress in spinning
structures like this would decrease as
you move away from the rotational center
this means it would need a stronger
structure the closer you get to the
center this clearly influenced their
design with these tapering spokes but we
run into some problems when a realized
sir isn't enough aluminium in the world
to build this thing it would take at
least ten years worth of the world's
total aluminium production just to build
the structure this would cause a huge
surge in the cost of materiel an
alternative method could be sourcing the
materials from space this could reduce
the launch cost and there is plenty of
metallic material available on the moon
and near-earth asteroids so this
technology is definitely possible
our only barriers are launch costs and
material availability something on the
scale of Space Station V would be easily
achievable who knows maybe we'll be
traveling to space as tourists in the
near future once again thanks for
watching I look a bonus for you at the
end of this outro you can skip ahead or
wait to watch it
I'd like to thank my patreon supporters
bastion Nick and FG for helping me to
revise this video your support is really
appreciated
thank you if you'd like to see more
content or support real engineering the
links from my patreon Instagram Facebook
and Twitter accounts are below so I
promise to include this in my last video
but I couldn't figure out a way to
include it in this video in a seamless
way the centrifugal governor was used in
the industrial revolution to control the
amount of steam entering the steam
piston which was essential as supply and
demand can vary with fuel and load for
example if the engineer puts more coal
into the boiler the pressure will rise
and these masses will spin faster which
increases the centrifugal force and
pushes them outwards this raises this
leave up which in turn closes the valve
to reduce the amount of steam entering
the engine so the centrifugal governor
acts as a sensor to provide direct
mechanical feedback to control the speed
of the engine it is one of my favorite
inventions of the Industrial Revolution
thanks for watching till the end
everyone hope you liked the video and
feel free to ask me any questions on
Twitter